while are you bad [__] uncle
Joey D in the birds are chirpin it's
cloudy out but I don't give a [__] I'm
on a mission and so are you swinging
dick and giving up popsicles we're here
we made it
everybody else is complaining it's hump
day who gives a [__] this is the best
day to go out the rest of these
[__] all as [__] all sad is
[__] you're ready to swing they can stab
him or the [__] the [__] Larry she
understand me
we got some tremendous reef Atlanta we
got Skywalker
we got the heroin and we got something
my little brother Ross dude listen
whenever strike whenever Ross strikes
it's all over this weed is the type of
[__] that you smoked and you clear out
your schedule you don't tank you just
start getting [__] up thoughts
speaking of [__] up thoughts it's all
about you today
Podcast eight o'clock jiu jitsu 12 I got
a meeting at 2:15
you know me dawg I'm always [__] out
there trying to put something together
because you gotta make something out of
nothing sometimes [__] it putting the
pieces together everyday you just go
towards your [__] goal and rub them
out you keep them against the gate and
we're on the [__] you following
me [__] these [__] they can't deal
with you I thought you knew
I love it I love this part of it they
open up in the morning I smoked some
reef with my favorite [__] people
this [__] up on the podcast yeah a
little too [__] up
Jesus Christ every once in a while you
let yourself go you know I'm saying we
did some [__] ba-ba-boom bars we did
the cantaloupe [__] saltwater taffy
followed by some star once it was all
over but the shot and guess what we're
back tonight [__] so never fear
uncle Joey's here
you're down you're having a rough
morning who use a [__] write down on
paper what you want for the rest of the
day and tell these [__] to step
back you're showing up with a helmet the
[__] bazooka that's just the way it
is guys you're gonna have good days
you're gonna have bad days
[__] through life you start having
better days and pretty soon the bad days
go away just like [__] that you
understand but it's all up to you nobody
just wakes up with a boat in the
backyard the [__] big house
they gotta put the pieces together and
work for it you don't see me with no
[__] boat I'm storing a mission [__]
so give me a couple [__] weeks I'm
like Tony Montana and 84 a mil here a
mil there I can't find the mill but I
keep looking I went from Darwin those
two 20s that's what you got to do [__]
the dollar bills
we're looking for 20s tonight today was
scratching the twenties
we're looking for yard sticks we're like
Jews today we're looking on the floor
you don't say
we never see a Jew walking around
looking at his fault and [__] you
he goes around the floor something money
dropped the [__] 20 and jebal coke a
vicodin something get him saying suck my
some value like they say if you don't
look you're not gonna find but this reef
is on fire today I'll have to have a
[__] protein shake after this just to
[__] loosen me up a little bit
that's sitting that's that I got to show
next Thursday the 25th to get your
Memorial Day party started at the Ice
House just working out with uncle Joey
10 bucks I write down a bunch of notes
and we discuss them trying to get a new
[__] hour and that's the
old-fashioned way of doing it I need you
[__] now we giggle we laugh you
smoke a joint you get out of the house
for 10 [__] bucks you following me
who's better than uncle Joey I'm not
here to [__] around Joey what's with the
chitter chatter you're gonna spark hell
yeah it's heavy-duty this morning I hate
Chinese people yelling buds a tight ship
just how I like I'm glad you
[__] came by settle oh this is
what it's all about if you can't get
high with your family were you gonna get
in I understand what if I in Iowa you
want to get out with your [__] family
you want to sit around and relax
there's no cameras there's no
celebrities there's no girls in bikinis
it's just us
gentlemen couple fantastic women Cleo
[__] jewel you know we got some good
women in this [__] family too so open
up your eyes we got [__] Charlie up
and Toronto Manning the [__] [__] for
the church we got him out there Joey
what the [__] you talking about what's
with the ax beating sparked that boat
Hey
oh yeah you see what you [__] people
put me through every morning I'm out
here with you [__] cuz you know
what charlie don't surf [__] uncle Joey
does beside that that's it and that's
that I'm strolling to the [__] gills
man I hope you are too I hope you have a
great day I hope you go out and give
them [__] hell don't take nothing from
nobody they're not running a charity out
there [__] it's you to take you
know oh it's used to give up you want to
give it up give it up but if it's right
there you got to pick it up and [__]
take your [__] worry about the pieces
later you don't say you want to make an
omelet you got to break a few [__]
eggshells so [__] them you grab your
balls you look him in the eye you say
I'm running this [__] [__] play
I see I see comas as I said it
anyway I love you [__] from the
bottom of my heart my fat little chubby
cocaine-induced heart I will see you
[__] tonight 8:00 p.m. be there
or be square tremendous guest tonight
don't worry about nothing I got your
back watch y'all [__] back all right
uncle Joey loves you see you [__]
tonight eight o'clock
have a great day don't let nobody
[__] even think the [__] much I'm
saying